let's see if we get a little bit more
practice and intuition of what
cross products are all about so in the
last example we took a cross b let's see
what happens when we take
b cross a
so let me let me erase some of this
let me erase i don't want to erase all
of it because it might be useful to give
us an intuition to compare
so let's say
i'm going to keep that
actually i can erase this i think
okay
let me see
okay so these the things i have drawn
here this was
a cross b let me
coordinate off
so that you don't get confused
so that was me using the right hand rule
when i tried to do a
cross b
and then we saw that the unit the the
the magnitude of this was 25
and n the the direction pointed into
pointed downwards or when i drew it here
it would point into the page so let's
see what happens with
b cross a so i just i'm just switching
the order
b cross a
well the magnitude is going to be the
same thing right because i'm still going
to take the magnitude of b
times the magnitude of a
times the sine of the angle between them
which was always pi over 6
radians
and then times some unit vector n
but this is going to be the same when i
multiply scalar quantities it doesn't
matter what order i multiply them in
right so this is still going to be
25 whatever my units might have been
times some vector n
and we still know that that vector n has
to be perpendicular to both a and b
and now we have to figure out well is it
in being perpendicular can either kind
of point into the page here or it could
pop out of the page or point out of the
page so which one is it and then we take
our right hand out and we try it again
so what we do is we take a right hand
and let's see if i can
i'm actually drawing my i'm using my
right hand right now although you can't
see it just to make sure i draw the
right thing
so in this example if i take my right
hand
i take the index finger
in the direction of b
i take my middle finger in the direction
of a so my middle finger
is going to look something like that
right and then i have two left over
fingers there
then the thumb goes in the direction
of the cross product
right because your thumb has a right
angle right there
that's the right angle of your thumb so
in this example if this is
that's the direction of a
this is the direction of b
and we're doing b cross a that's why b
gets your index finger
the index finger gets the first term
your middle finger gets the second term
and the thumb gets the direction of the
cross product so in this example the
direction of the cross product is
upwards
or in this
when we're drawing in two dimensions
right here the cross product would
actually pop out of the page for b cross
a
so
i'll write draw it over it would be the
circle with the dot or if i were to draw
analogous to this
so this is
this right here that was a
cross b
and then b cross a is the exact same
magnitude but it goes in the other
direction
that's b cross a
it just flips the opposite direction and
that's why you have to use your right
hand because you might know that oh
something's going to pop in or out of
the page et cetera et cetera but you
need to know your right hand to to know
whether it goes in or out of the page
anyway let's see if you can get a little
bit more intuition of what this is all
about because this is all about
intuition and frankly i'll tell you the
the cross product comes into use into a
lot of concepts that frankly we don't
have a lot of real life intuition with
you know electrons flying through a
magnetic field or magnetic field through
a coil and a lot of things that you know
in our everyday life experience maybe if
we if we were metal filings living in a
magnetic field our entire well we do
live in a magnetic field in a strong
magnetic field maybe we would get an
intuition but it's hard to have as deep
of an intuition as we do for say falling
objects
or friction or forces or fluid dynamics
even because we've all played with water
but anyway let's get a little bit more
intuition and let's think about why is
there that sine of theta you know why i
just multiply the magnitudes times each
other and use the right hand rule and
figure out a direction what is that sine
of theta all about and i think i need to
i need to
clear this up a little bit just so you
you can
be
this could be useful
so why is that sine of theta there
let's let me draw redraw some vectors
i'll draw them a little fatter
so let's say that's a
that's a
this is b
b doesn't always have to be longer than
a i just
so this is a
and this is b
now we could think of a little bit we
could say well this is the same thing as
a sine theta times b or we could say
this is b sine theta times
a i hope i'm not confused all i'm saying
is you can interpret this as this could
also be written as because these are
just magnitudes right so it doesn't
matter what order you multiply them in
you could say this is a sine theta
times
the magnitude of b
all of that in the direction of the
normal vector or you could put the sine
theta other way but let's think about
what this would mean a sine theta if
this is theta
what is a sine theta
sine is opposite over hypotenuse right
so opposite over hypotenuse
so this would be
the vector the magnitude of a
if i were to drop let me draw something
let me draw a line here
and make it a real line
let me draw a line there so i have a
right angle
i have a right angle right there
so it's a sine theta and this is the
opposite side
so a sine theta is a and what sine of
theta is opposite over hypotenuse the
hypotenuse is the magnitude of a
right
so sine of theta is equal to this side
which i call o for opposite
opposite
over the magnitude of a so it's
opposite over the magnitude of a
so this term a sine theta is actually
just the magnitude
of this line
right here
another way you could let me let me
redraw it
i could it doesn't matter where the
vectors start from all you care about is
this magnitude direction so you can
shift vectors around
so this
vector right here you could call it this
opposite vector that's the same thing as
this vector
that's the same thing as this i just
shift it
away
and so another way to think about it is
it is the component of vector a
right we're used to taking a vector and
splitting it up into
you know x and y components but now
we're taking a vector a and we're
splitting it up into
you could think of it as a component
that's parallel
to vector b and a component that is
perpendicular to vector b
so a sine theta
is the magnitude of
the the component of vector a that is
perpendicular to b
so what when you're taking the cross
product of two numbers you're kind of
saying well i don't care about the
entire magnitude of say vector a in this
example i care about the magnitude of
vector a that is perpendicular to vector
b
and those are the two numbers that i
want to multiply
and then give it that direction as
specified by the right hand rule and
i'll show you some applications this is
especially important well we will we'll
use it in torque and we'll also use it
in magnetic fields
but but it's it's important in both of
those applications to figure out the
components of the vector
that are perpendicular to either a force
or radius in question so that's why this
this cross product has the sine theta
because we're taking so in this if you
view it as magnitude of a sine theta
times b
this is kind of saying
this is the magnitude of the of the
component of a perpendicular to b
or you can interpret it the other way
you can interpret it as
a
times b sine theta
right if put a parenthesis here and then
you could do it the other way you could
say well b sine theta is the component
is the component of b that is
perpendicular to a let me draw that just
to hit the point home
so that's my a
that's
my b
so b is how well this is a
this is b so b has some component of it
that is perpendicular to a and that is
going to look something like well i kind
of run out of space let me draw it here
if that's a
that's b
the the component of b that is
perpendicular to a is going to look like
this i'll turn a different color
it's going to be perpendicular to a and
it's going to go that far
right
and then you could go back to sohcahtoa
and you could prove to yourself that the
magnitude of this vector
is b sine theta so that is where the
sine theta comes from it makes sure that
we're not just multiplying the vectors
and make sure we're multiplying the
components of the vectors that are
perpendicular to each other to get a
third vector that is perpendicular to
both of them and then you know the
people who invented the the cross
product said well it's still ambiguous
because it doesn't tell us there's
always two vectors that's perpendicular
to these two one goes in one goes out
they're in opposite directions and
that's where the right hand rule comes
in they'll say okay well we'll just
we're just going to say a convention
that you use your right hand point it
like a gun make all your fingers
perpendicular and then you know whether
what direction that vector points in
anyway hopefully you're not confused now
i want you to watch the next video and
this is actually going to be some
physics on
electricity magnetism and torque and
that's essentially the applications of
the cross product and it'll give you a
little bit more intuition of how to use
it see you soon